my talk of the table we've got an
exclusive announcement from one of our
favorite authors
guess who it is
hi everyone i'm renee brown and on
november 30th i am releasing a brand new
book called atlas of the heart
and it is a book about finding our way
back to ourselves and to each other
especially in the midst of a lot of
uncertainty
anxiety and
fear
it's a book about building grounded
competence
having the courage to walk alongside
people
and becoming really powerful stewards of
the stories we share and the stories we
hear
thank you renee brown i love everything
about her she already has five
best-selling books including dare to
lead and braving the wilderness she also
gave one of the top five most viewed ted
talks in the world with more than 50
million views and lucky us we get
renee's first tv interview and atlas of
the heart drops that's the new term
drops on november 30th i always feel
cool when i say that that's what renee
says she says i want this book to be an
atlas for all of us because i believe
that an adventurous heart and the right
maps we can travel anywhere and never
fear losing ourselves even when we don't
know where we are this is the thing that
always strikes me about her she always
seems to to me say the right words at
the right time for whatever you're going
through even when you don't even know
even when she doesn't know what you're
going through just a conversation with
her i feel like i need a pad and a
pencil that's why it's not just five
books she's got five number one
best-selling books which i'm sure this
will be number six here's my favorite
tony talk to yourself like you would to
someone you love we're always beating
ourselves up don't do that good i love
it don't do that thank you i'm going to
try that
i'm going to try it starting now beating
myself 30th